we need to talk about this common
mistake that is hurting the majority of
YouTube creators growth and as we unpack
this I first want to talk about what
most creators are doing that is not
working and so I'm curious what creators
do you follow you know what
entrepreneurs business owners do you
follow there's a lot of people who maybe
follow Gary vaynerchuk they're trying to
like imitate his success maybe you've
seen Sniper Wolf she's one of the most
followed subscribed female creators Mr
Beast of course everyone's like doing
what Mr Beast is saying to do all that
kind of stuff maybe you've seen Erica
kohlberg crushing it going viral
launching a video podcast maybe you see
Alex hermosi blowing up but here's the
mistake people are making copying
successful people won't make you
successful
the truth is you don't have their team
you don't got the budget you don't have
their experience you don't have their
connections you don't have their
momentum and so there's really A Better
Way Forward and this might seem like
contrarian advice but I promise you if
you stick with me I'm going to be
revealing four tips and really the key
to what you can learn from successful
people but without falling into the Trap
that's keeping a lot of channels small
and stopping them from growing but
today's coffee with candle is brought to
you by vid IQ a little bit more on them
later and uh welcome to the show smash
like if you're getting value but here's
the big idea copying successful people
will not make you successful the key is
copying how successful people started
one of the things that's keeping so many
creators small is the fact that they are
imitating and copying creators that are
super established they've got big teams
they've got big budgets and the problem
is you also don't see behind this scenes
you don't know their story my friend
John Acuff always says never compare
your beginning to somebody else's middle
if you're imitating somebody's middle or
comparing yourself to somebody else's
middle when you're at the start that is
a recipe for discouragement it's a
recipe for the loss of Joy it's a recipe
for also taking and doing the wrong
actions that will keep you small for
example did you know that Gary
vaynerchuk recommends that you make 64
pieces of content a day like Gary
basically says like what are you even
doing if you're not posting 64 pieces of
original content a day like do you even
have value as a human being if you don't
post 64 pieces of content a day you're
not gonna make it you might as well quit
now I mean like thanks Gary for nothing
that's literally his advice like he is
literally telling people years ago it's
probably a bigger number now he's like
here's you should be posting 64 pieces
of content a day
see that's a problem because if you're
just getting started with a lower level
of or trying to learn new skills
not having a budget not having a team
then that actually advice could be some
of the most harmful advice that you
could ever get so I want to talk about
four tips that can really help us
actually succeed faster and avoid the
Trap that most creators are falling into
and let me know is there any what
creators do you like to follow what
creators do you like to get advice from
or what creators do you like to you know
watch or business owners who are some of
your favorites tell me in the comments
um but I have good news because
ultimately it's not about your resources
it's about your resourcefulness because
where you could go here is you could say
well Sean if I if I'm not supposed to
imitate big creators and if I can't do
64 pieces of content a day and if I
don't have all this stuff well then you
know what should I do well the good news
is every big creator that you follow
every successful business owner that you
follow every person that's built a brand
or a personal brand or an online
business they did all start at zero they
did all start not from where they are
today now sure maybe some had an
inheritance maybe some had somebody else
shout them out maybe some had some
things that you don't have like they had
an unfair Advantage but one common theme
you will find in the journey Arc the
hero's journey of success is that
basically everybody started off with
some type of a disadvantage they all
started off with something where they
had a lack of resources and they had to
find a way to be resourceful and that's
the opportunity for you and me so let's
just briefly talk about four tips for
faster YouTube and online business
success this is the coffee with Channel
show and so after this I'm gonna do some
live coaching with four special guests
I'll take some of your questions if
you're watching on the replay we're
gonna go for about another five minutes
and you could always check out the time
codes and chapters but also I think
you'll get value from some of these
conversations in Q a as well and so
let's dive into number one
don't model where they are now model how
they got there
it's a mistake to imitate the successful
because again you can't see behind the
scenes to what they're doing now but the
question is where do they start like
what did they do at the start that I
could learn from I think a lot of us
could benefit more from studying the
origin story and the early days which is
hard information to get sometimes but
when you can find the nuggets from the
early days that's what you want to
imitate don't model where they are now
model how they got there see a lot of
people are trying to make Mr B Style
videos and you don't got a million
dollars to spend per video and hundreds
of people to work on the project but
Jimmy Donaldson he started back in 2012
and did you know that he was posting for
five years before he got significant
popularity
right around 2017 his counting to a
hundred thousand video was the one that
really started to kind of pop pop off
but oftentimes it's generally understood
that you have to post well over a
hundred videos before getting
substantial recognition if any momentum
at all a hundred videos you want to know
the mistake that most creators are
making judging their results after three
videos judging the results after 33
videos judging your results after
posting for a few weeks or a few months
or even a year Mr Beast was posting for
five years and you're like judging
yourself after five weeks and getting
all in your head and emotional about
things relax Rebecca
take a chill pill Paul like we gotta we
gotta take a step back like this stuff
takes time YouTube is a marathon and not
a Sprint
you know Gary vaynerchuk who today is
got an entirely different thing going on
had originally one show not 64 pieces of
content a day one show called Wine
Library TV this was like the full
resolution like what you see on screen
like that's like the high that was the
original resolution of the show it was
shot in like 480p on a camcorder he had
he was working at his dad's wine store
and liquor store and he started to make
a a live not live but like a one take
wine review show he went a thousand
episodes that was what brought him to
original popularity but then after that
he launched a new business vaynermedia
and didn't even post content for about
three years because he was doing
business operations hiring people
getting things going and so when you
look at someone's trajectory I feel like
he has like 10 million Instagram
followers or something now like you look
at him today I think he has 20 25 30
people just on his personal brand Team
and then he's got like 1300 in his other
company so again you're hearing people
like the the whatever internet Guru
recommend this or that tactic and I'm
not saying there's not value there I'm
saying the key is self-awareness for
what season you're in and when you're
applying the advice this is the miss
this this whole this keeps people small
it gets it keeps people discouraged and
it holds people back because when you're
imitating the actions of somebody that's
at year five or year seven in their
journey and you're on day seven you're
setting yourself up to be frustrated and
potentially also have the advice
backfire and not ultimately work number
two is play to your strengths and
minimize your weaknesses
I want to encourage you one of the
biggest mistakes we make is trying to be
somebody else is trying to imitate
somebody else's strengths there's only
one you you got to be you times two I
gotta be me times three like ultimately
so dumb like ultimately like you gotta
like play your strengths though you know
you got to figure out okay what do I
have going for me like maybe you love
research so making video essay faceless
type of YouTube videos would be great
for you maybe you love interviewing
people and you love to like buy their
books read their books interview people
so a video podcast would be great for
you maybe you love complex things and
you don't need to make videos simple you
need to make like highly technical
videos maybe you like simple things and
so you love to work on something that
makes complex things simple so you could
take a topic and make a Channel with
like beginner advice in your Niche your
topic you gotta find your angle you got
to play to your strengths don't try to
be somebody else you're going to be you
know you were born an original don't die
a copy you know just like personal
development platitudes just you know
like everyone has quoted that whatever
it's still a good quote though you were
born in original don't die a copy it
makes me think about Mary's nest
you know Mary started YouTube when she
was 60 years old she actually joined our
program called video ranking Academy 60
years old like she couldn't play to her
strength of being a dancing gen Z
hipster you know like she had to play to
the strengths of the fact that she loved
traditional cooking she loved sauerkraut
and sourdough bread and fermenting
things and apple cider vinegar and she
had developed this passion for her whole
life she also isn't crazy like high
energy jump cut YouTube editing she's
not crashing chain trains into giant
sinkholes you know or comparing billion
dollar lots Yachts it's completely her
playing to her own strengths so she
started her YouTube channel making
simple videos she started to invest in
her skills and today she started at 60.
this year she's 65 years old she's gonna
hit a million subscribers Mary's Nest is
getting a gold play button round him
Random House gave Mary a book deal like
what are we talking about and so there's
too many people out there that are like
YouTube is just for this type of person
or that type of person it's just for
people living in this country or that
country and the truth is it's an equal
opportunity platform like you just gotta
play to your strengths you got to be
resourceful you got to figure out your
unique difference position yourself
according to that and downplay your
weaknesses like I suck at a lot of stuff
most things really I just want to play
to the strengths that I have and create
the best content possible for me you
know Sophia armor Russo said true
success lies in knowing your weaknesses
and playing to your strengths
self-awareness is a superpower
not trying to imitate somebody's content
that it's not meant for you but really
figuring out your own path in your own
way number three take massive messy
action
you know when you're comparing your
beginning to somebody else's middle I
sometimes worry because some people
um when they start YouTube they don't
understand that like there's some
sacrifice that goes into this
and I know that some people maybe today
are are still hustling and still
sacrificing depending on like what
season of Life they're in but I actually
am I'm worried because sometimes
younger entrepreneurs they might see I
mean I'm still hustling pretty hard but
they might see like where where I'm at
today or whatever with my family I got a
couple kids I got a little more margin
in my life you know this week our team
think media people that work at our
company they're gonna get six weeks off
six weeks including federal holidays a
Sabbath week where we're going to be
shutting our company down no content for
a week
um holidays a few extra days plus their
two weeks plus you like you add it all
up counting six days it could be like
more than six weeks off I think media is
a pretty cool company to work for you
should apply but if you think about it
like like there to build where I got
today I wasn't getting six weeks off bro
like I wasn't getting six weeks off
Karen like I I had to there was certain
things I did in certain seasons and
there's something about taking massive
messy action now I know two people in
the in the chat in the comments might be
like oh bro you're just talking about
hustle culture I'm not talking about
hustle culture I'm just talking about
the law of sacrifice you got to give up
to go up and it's not something that you
do for life we're not talking about
burnout here we're just talking about
there's a certain season where like
you're hustling on the weekends you're
working after work you're you're doing
things in off hours like if you really
want this thing so sometimes when you're
comparing where what like the actions
you're doing today to where somebody
else is later you didn't realize they
got out Automation and a team and
different things happening at the
beginning tip number three you gotta
take massive messy action you know it
reminds me of a brand new podcast we
just dropped with Michael Zuber if you
haven't subscribed to the think media
podcast and you haven't watched this
episode I highly recommend it we'll make
sure it's in the show notes but Michael
Zuber also started his YouTube channel
after he retired he was working in
Silicon Valley kind of got bored
um and realized like he had to keep
doing something so he started a YouTube
channel he doesn't edit his videos which
is kind of cool why you should watch the
episode he's doing something like over
eighty thousand dollars a year right now
in YouTube ad Revenue over like three
hundred four hundred thousand dollars in
multiple streams of income
and he started this YouTube channel in
retirement it's called one rental at a
time and he's posted over 10 000 videos
it's something it's like 11 000 videos
like the thing is he's just taken
massive messy action for some they might
say well he could polish his videos a
little bit more they could have this
opinion or that opinion but the funny
thing is that everyone who's got
opinions usually aren't doing like 80k
and AD revenue and 380k across the way
you know what I mean like everybody's
got opinions but you got to take massive
messy action like you got to get out
there and just put in the work and put
in the hustle you know when I was
starting these videos on screen are 12
years old one of the reasons why I've
had uh I think success on YouTube today
is because I've had so many failures in
the past like in the past I've
ultimately
failed I have like three or four Failed
YouTube channels and by failures I just
mean that like I posted a lot of videos
that channel never worked out
But ultimately failures are the Stepping
Stones to success I was just taking
massive messy action and the more videos
you post the more failures you have the
more lessons you have because sometimes
we win
and sometimes we learn
and so you got to take massive messy
action and I got tip number four for you
in just a second but I do want to shout
out our sponsor today vid IQ one of the
things that is helpful and one of the
things I wish I had especially early in
my journey with some of the new tools
that vid IQ is giving us right now if
you go to vidiq.com forward slash think
you could get a 30-day trial of an iq's
boost plan for just one dollar but I'm
curious what topics are your channels
about shout me out in the comments what
topics is your Channel about I'm going
to use their daily ideas tool for one of
your channels but what's cool is once
you connect vid IQ to your channel I
have it connected to our main Channel
think media
It ultimately gives you ideas
every day
based on a view prediction
so this title the coolest streaming
camera in webcam ever that's a great
idea and it's a great title it's a good
angle on it I'm going to heart that one
and that puts it on a list of videos
that we could make there are 7 500
YouTube channel describe uh disappeared
overnight find out what happened
interesting so if you knew what that
story was avoid this YouTube automation
mistake pretty good if you were an
expert in automation faceless channels
um the surprising truth about
smartphones so you could go through here
these eight III Mac apps are going viral
for a reason and again you don't have to
actually do eight AI Mac apps you might
do three but you're like okay great that
actually I'm like what are the apps
might send you down a path of research
to go find out what it is and so uh
threads versus Twitter nice the ultimate
social media Showdown it's a better
title than my threads video should have
used vid IQ so anyways uh this is kind
of a cool tool and I want to grab one of
your channels
um we're gonna look at the carriage
house thing thanks so much for being
here on coffee with candle we're going
to look up homemaking and we're gonna go
customize ideas and so if we head over
here you could do customize ideas
how to become a successful Homemaker
your no-nonsense guide 50 ways to use
mason jars
is there seriously 50 ways to use mason
jars pretty sick idea because if I hit
that I go okay what are the ways maybe
it's not 50 you could change the number
I also think as I'm shooting all the
b-roll if you actually do all that work
you could turn it into different
listicles related to like a short like
you could you could just show as a
potted plant flower thing as a plant
thingy you know like as a thing for
water as a thing for coffee with candles
okay relax
um and so anyways that's that's a good
one I'm not going to Heart it because
it's not my channel biblical homemaking
interesting angle if that was and and
what's cool about this tool is it can
give you inspiration and it's giving you
a view prediction based on them studying
all of the velocity of videos on YouTube
how many views they're getting and by
the way this is just one tool this is
only the daily ideas tool from vid IQ
and so vid IQ has been a sponsor for a
while we love them
but also
um even well before they were a sponsor
I've been a vid IQ User it's been a big
part of my journey and so if you want to
check out a one dollar
trial 30-day trial of the vid IQ boost
plan super worth it
um and get some results over the next 30
days let's land the plane on number four
learn as fast as you can
we're talking about four tips for
succeeding faster and not falling in the
mistake of comparing our beginning to
somebody else's middle
and so learn as fast as you can this is
Eric Reese and Eric Reese is a startup
investor he's uh best known uh for his
book The Lean Startup it's a New York
Times best-selling book
he's an entrepreneur blogger and he has
extensive experience in the startup
World by the way as a content creator
you are a startup founder maybe you
didn't think about it that way you're
like Sean relax it's just a hobby okay
but but for real like you're like you're
a business owner you're starting a
startup actually if you don't think that
way it's the better mindset to have like
like Jay-Z said
I'm not a businessman I am a business
comma man like you're a business you're
starting a startup you're starting a
media company might be a small one it
might just be on the side but you got a
side Media company that you're launching
and so when we look at A Book Like The
Lean Startup great book by the way and
of course you can always check out our
show notes
um when we look at A Book Like The Lean
Startup there was a quote in this book
that I think can change all of our lives
and here's what it is
the only way to win is to learn faster
than anyone else
I think that when we're just starting if
we want to succeed faster we don't want
to imitate people's year 10 because
we're in year one we want to figure out
what did they do when they started what
were their moves to go from zero to one
to get what was their original shortest
path to income what was the original way
that they hired their first VA or person
like oh I can't hire a teen because I
can't hire an HR person and do a health
care program and pay some of the 80k
salary and do obviously but like what
did they do when they just got started
like you could still probably hire and
scale a lot faster you got to figure
those things out the only way to win is
to learn faster than anyone else and I
know I'm preaching to the choir if
you're part of the coffee with candle
show if you're a part of our community
you uh probably subscribe to our think
media podcast or maybe you're a part of
our challenge or whatever else but I
just want to encourage you you want to
succeed faster learn faster this is a
proven principle of startup success of
business success and I believe of
YouTube YouTube success and so we could
take it from Eric and take it from think
media this is going to give you an
advantage as we get ready for coffee
with candle today I do want to invite
you if you haven't actually registered
yet for our free five-day challenge
right now we're actually in the middle
of the live challenge but the cool thing
is even if you missed some sessions you
can get access to
the replays for free and so we have four
on-demand sessions available right now
you could go to tube1kchallenge.com
enter your info like on the next page as
soon as you get into our Circle Group
which is like just a private group where
we're hosting it boom you can start
watching these super powerful sessions
we've been blown away by the feedback
we've been getting and this is going to
help you get your first or next 1 000
subscribers and
if you already have a thousand
subscribers there's a lot of established
channels that are like man this
information is way better than I thought
it was going to be so anyways if you
want to check it out solely free to
boincaidchallenge.com we do have another
live session and we have a couple bonus
things that are happening next week so
definitely head to tube1kchallenge.com
if you've been a part of it shout me out
in the comments um if you've got any
takeaways or if you've enjoyed the
challenge and with that I want to
welcome you to the uh coffee with candle
show that was our 22 minute opener but
this show is where we um sip on coffee
so let me know what you're drinking
Today's Show is brought to you by uh
Presta Coffee Roasters not really but
that's what I'm sipping on and I thought
like I might start doing uh hey Sean
what are you drinking and so roasted in
the Tucson Arizona desert
sipping our little uh Rwanda
with orange blossom cranberry oolong tea
notes full bodied and so we're out here
man coffee with candle officially let me
know what you're drinking and we're
going to be doing some live coaching
with a couple of guests today and so I'm
so fired up thanks for being here here
we go
[Music]
back to the coffee with Canal show today
we have Paul Lewis Debbie and Stacy
coming on the show I'm gonna have Paul
jump on here in just a second if you
have a question you could put the
question
um question marks before and after your
question and we'll start those and get
to as many as we can thank you Kix TV
for the generous Super Chat no message
just love and so appreciate you for that
twenty dollars and glad you're getting
value here means the world
um we have uh Paul on deck and we're
gonna bring you on the show today from
the trooper trance Mission what's up
Paul what's going on
and so uh Paul tell us about what you're
doing I'll pull your channel up and then
uh we'll talk about your question
describe your channel to us yeah it's
Star Wars and fitness and I basically
just want to use Star Wars as a trojan
horse to help people get better in a
health and fitness capacity man very
creative so so people are getting fit
you're on here let's check this out how
long you been doing this uh May 4th I
launched my first video and I'm coming
up on a hundred since then
awesome Okay cool so um what do you want
to talk about today
yeah I made it because truly I wanted to
make it I thought it would be fun no one
was like hey will you make workouts in a
clone trooper helmet and I was like I'll
just do it like I've said I would do it
I'll do it and then it it's done really
well on like Instagram Tick Tock my
Instagram's gone like 55 000 followers
in less than three months and I know
people enjoy it because I get messages
every single day of people being like
I'm doing this in Spain my unit overseas
is doing this I'm doing this with my
kids
but the thing that just is taken every
single time is like a 0.8 click through
rate on on these videos and so because
I'm creating so many so often I'm not
taking the you know to your point in the
video like
what Mr Beast does with his thumbnail
I'm not taking that approach I'm just
like all right cool what's like a copy
and paste approach I can use and I'm
just mimicking what I see other Fitness
creators do in their titles and
headlines but I'm like
is I'm just yeah I'm not sure how to
make this and it may the answer might be
it's not a big viral thumbnail title
thing it's just like continue to beat
the drum
why did
this do a little bit better why did this
get 25 uh 24 000 views do you think yeah
it um I had a video on Tick Tock that I
also shared on Instagram do they both
did two million in like two days and it
was basically like hey you want to do
Clone Trooper workouts here's where it
is and so I got 3 000 Subs in two days
but why I mean
specifically the views like so this went
like do you think you're saying Tick
Tock and Instagram is why this on a day
yeah because this is this is day one of
the first 30 day challenge I did so if
anyone was like oh I want to do the
challenge so I've played with numbering
the videos I've played with not
numbering because if someone sees it on
their discover feed I don't again I
don't know them just like testing this
but does it feel too overwhelming to be
like oh this is the sixth video I can't
watch this one I need to start at the
first
yeah I mean it's one it's it's really
cool what you're doing two it's cool to
see I mean it's Unique
um
it's novel and that novelty I could
definitely understand why vertical Tick
Tock and stuff would maybe get shared or
get some views because it stops the
scroll tops Taps into a fandom
the downsides are
the staying power like someone that's
saying okay if I'm scrolling on tick
tock
it's going to be almost impossible for
you to get me motivated out of scrolling
and like into a 25 minute upper body
workout like it's not right like oh
Paul's telling me you know so like that
transaction is going to be tough the
flip side is if I'm searching on YouTube
utility wise for a workout for men or an
upper body workout
um the intent is different it's like
straight to the point like I I just want
and perhaps I find that and I'm like you
know well I had no idea I was going to
find a 25 minute upper body workout and
I'd much rather work out with the Storm
Trooper than uh somebody who isn't one
and so let's go for it but that bridge
is kind of tough and obviously you've
probably also seen that some of your
best videos were what you were doing
before this which were like what more
lore more kind of video essays tapping
into the fandom that could have more
repeat repeat viewers correct right
so I mean I think you already kind of
know what challenge you're up against uh
you know what is interesting is if you
apply the a thousand true fans principle
um and where to create like enough true
fans that just are really
into this you know like they just they
want to be a part of a coaching program
where they get in shape and they're like
they love both Star Wars and they want
that but sometimes Market message match
might be a little bit tough here for the
sustainability and I think that's what
you're seeing with like your latest
videos you know if I click subscribe as
well it's like the big question I have
is what am I subscribing for what's your
answer to that
Star Wars themed workouts
yeah and I mean makes sense how many
people do you think you know woke up
today and were like you know what I need
in my life
Star Wars themed workouts
not a ton
so where you think you should go from
here
the well where everything ends up is a
coaching program where it is like hey
Fitness Academy is for nerds who also
want to lose weight and so you've got
people yeah I mean I've got people going
through the first wave now I've got
other people who've been like I'm
interested so that's why I say it is
very much a trojan horse It's
Entertainment 80 of people are going to
fall off as soon as there's actually
some work that they need to do Beyond
just passively viewing
but if it's a and that that's where I
came from is high ticket Fitness and I
was like I just want to Niche down yeah
and so if I'm only getting
you know tens or twenties of people a
month who are actually serious about
this like that's fine are you already
doing that yeah
so actually everything's fine
yeah ultimately
well that's good news and that's
encouraging because it's it shows that
you can keep having fun doing this
multi-platform Lincoln bio I think then
practically the only thing I would say
is number one like the fact you solved
that first is a big lesson for our
community like financially things are
fine the math of your content your
videos across platforms
uh connects to your offer and the amount
of customers you need
and so you have money for the mission am
I correct yeah and so now you can
continue to develop this out with more
creativity my my initial thought liking
the idea is
is thumbnail Improvement on the one hand
like I'm not a huge fan of
of like how much is happening uh I guess
here it's it's sort of confusing I guess
it's clear because of the words but the
fact you've got the picture in picture
the fact that
you know
I would like maybe a little more
Simplicity I also wonder
if entertainment what performs best here
shorts do they perform best kind of like
on Tick Tock yeah add a bunch of lore
shorts that helped with the channel
initially and then I was just like this
isn't a sustainable thing if I want to
just make it more Fitness based right
okay but I mean could you do some some
that are like um
or do you have Fitness shorts doing good
on like tick tock not not the way that
the other ones were the other ones were
story based and I would spend like 10
minutes on a hook to get people
drawn in but that took an hour and I was
like I could take an hour film a video
and like I was looking at numbers now
I've got 89 leads through the click
funnels free giveaway it's like a recipe
list in the last seven days and so
that's where I'm like oh if a video did
ten thousand
right then I'd be able to video do you
think what'd you say from what video or
from just all of them I put the same
train like a trooper recipe list in all
of the comments
on on even these old shorts or you're
talking new stuff no just the new
workout ones
new workout shorts not not shorts just
just the long form videos
gotcha so if we go here and so so that a
that's working and B what's also cool is
you're getting the right people yes
because they want to this this is where
the leads are coming from is right here
yeah okay that's great
um yeah I mean for what it's worth
hoping to add some value is I do think
thumbnail best practice would be
interesting and I do think kind of an
edutainment play
where
where you're taking you clearly have a
lot of knowledge
where maybe how do you hybridize to
become the most famous person in the
world
that scene with some viral workout
vertical videos or some kind of viral
you know
yeah I've grabbed people's attention go
broad pinned comment link in the
description and then kind of build up
the celebrity around the the trooper
transmission you know brand I think that
does that make sense I mean yeah that I
mean that's my two fears is one to not
be taken serious enough and so that's
why like different platforms and
channels need to have different level of
like this is viral content this is
educational like in my Facebook group I
go live with a q a and show what people
are doing inside of the academy and then
the other fear I have is if it at any
point Disney's like yo what are you
doing stop using this to Market your
business yeah uh yeah is anybody I mean
you're one of one do you know anybody
else doing it no do you know anybody
else that's doing cosplay Star Wars on
YouTube and getting away with it at a
big level
cost yo yeah cosplay all that stuff I
mean they love that because that just
shares it's kind of what you're doing
yeah and that's what it is and that's
what my headline on my BSL is cosplay
with confidence have you uh I like that
have you um thought about collaborations
I have I'm just one man right now so I'm
a little I think collaborating
um you could have some probably pretty
Banger videos especially if you
collaborated with like a female Star
Wars
cosplay and fitness I would say what
you're doing right now A reach out you
know and see like that would be worth
doing a few videos I think that could be
interesting and then I think also
embracing I like I love what you said
what when you said my two biggest fears
I think we could all spend some time
asking ourselves what are our biggest
fears that are holding us back and good
fears because sometimes fear is like
take caution the copyright stuff that's
interesting
um but also
I mean of course there's gonna be people
who don't take you seriously but who
cares like we were never able to please
everybody anyways and the and the truth
about virality which you already know is
as soon as on the other side of the
virality is trolls every single time as
soon as something starts getting big
views it comes with good and bad in
terms of comments especially all comment
sections but on Tick Tock I mean Tick
Tock comments are a dumpster fire like
it's just wild over there so being okay
with that but I do think I do think
tapping into some entertainment
and on the long tail it just becomes
awareness of your exact brand and it
kind of relates to me like you remember
uh it was like nerd Fitness yeah yeah
he's he's amused very much where it's
like what did he do
um I feel like I'm just niching even
further within that and it proves that
model is like you said amused it proves
that it kind of works I think you could
even kind of be the 3.0 version of that
and I've often referenced nerd Fitness
as like a great way to Niche down and a
Cool brand but I want to say they never
really embass video
yeah it was all like blogs like a Blog
yeah so so you kind of going deeper
there
yeah I hope some of that and I do think
I would like maybe audit the market I
think a collaboration
um just specifically knowing that I mean
even Comic-Con this whole scene which I
you know better than me but
like going to an event like that
pre-scheduling some collabs with people
and if you could find the overlap of
like they also work out they also and
potentially make entertainment videos
for the reach of it because it's just
reached to the channel reach to
awareness you already have the business
sustainable so you just add on more
awareness to that it just gets bigger
systematize things more team around the
whole deal
um any final question is this been
helpful Paul yeah super helpful and
one last question I'd have is if at any
point does it make sense to have a lower
ticket lower threshold
purchase for the audience because I'll
get a lot of you know 22 year olds who
are like hey I want to go through your
coaching program I'm like it I have to
financially disqualify them just and
also probably life stage as well
um because I'm really going after like
people in the military or fathers who
are more Star Wars fans but then I'm
like would they at what point does it
make sense to maybe be more hands off
have a lower tier price point but I also
don't want to cannibalize what I do from
a high ticket standpoint as well
absolutely it does I I don't think it
cannibalize it I think it adds to it and
I think it's a self-awareness piece as
well I think what could be interesting
is a continuity
um membership of some kind I'm not a big
fan of Channel memberships just because
YouTube takes 30 percent you obviously
in the clickfunnels world know you could
host memberships otherwise where but
that that reoccurring Revenue could be
powerful lower ticket like
some level of more more diet more
workouts more content exclusive content
of some kind at
you know something that's like people
are price and sensitive to like a five
dollar a month level and you could
crunch that idea
um or there obviously could be kind of
uh
something that is a digital product of
some kind that if you could get it
automated and sustainable I think it's a
it's a great idea and I think it's
particularly related to the fact that
number one you're also going to max out
clients anyways
um and once awareness continues to grow
like that I don't think it'll
cannibalize it my guess is like you
would always be full my also you always
have a waiting list I think that would
be the key is like your waiting list in
relation to working with you is maxed of
course bigger strategy is thinking if
you think far down the road and really
building this up is how do you also
build up additional coaches so the high
ticket doesn't cap out but I think you
could also consider the lower ticket and
try to have that you know automated
whether it's monthly reoccurring revenue
or it's more like a
um you know 97 kind of dollar program
and like a couple payments or something
and thinking about yeah I just picture
obviously there's some copyright things
even on The Branding of all of that but
I just picture like
I think like Dave Ramsey he's his
stuff's at like a book level a a 20 book
level and when they launched one of his
personalities launches something more
than that they have like a 50 level and
it comes with checklists and other
things for budgeting
um and it's a one he's massive I mean
massive man you know what I mean like
it's radio
Mass reach 20 million views a month on
his YouTube channel
and so you can play in both worlds
um and and so I think that could be a
part of
is a great idea okay cool
awesome Paul well I appreciate you
thanks so much for uh coming on coffee
with candle today yeah thank you so much
all right take care bye
so smash like for Paul and smash like
for getting in shape if uh if you don't
have a stormtrooper helmet yet it's time
to get one and head over to Trooper
transmission
um and get your stuff going I lost my
live comments this happened to me
earlier but I do still have my starred
comments so uh thank you for dropping
some questions in here
um organized biology says
what are some good stats that those vid
IQ ideas successfully work are there
some good stats
well
it's hard to say because their daily
video ideas are going to be still
predicated upon your
the 26 different details of how you
execute on the idea do you dial on the
the topic and the title well for
yourself do you make a good thumbnail is
your video supporting that title good
does it hook people is it good audience
retention are you brief bright fun done
are you and
it's not a magic pill as you take the
video idea
you know layer it on top of a pile of
poop
title it because nobody wants to watch
like a just okay it's a bad illustration
but you know nobody wants to just see
like a pile of garbage on
YouTube like and so I know you know that
but like the execution following that's
going to be a big deal saying that we
talk a lot here about topics being the
game like there's a million video ideas
you could make next
but the Right video idea at the right
time with the right thumbnail and the
right title with the right content is
the difference between a viral video or
a hundred thousand views and ten
thousand views or a thousand views and
10 views
so
you know when you have tools like that
they aren't magic in the sense of like
you just get vid IQ and then all of a
sudden poof it's like Fairy Godmother
dust and you just transform
your pumpkin into a carriage
I've never seen that work besides in the
movies but having the right tools can
definitely enhance what you're currently
doing and with that I think we've got uh
I think we got Lewis on deck and so I'm
excited I'm going to pull up Lewis's
Channel we're going to welcome Liz
actually wait who is
oh okay Lewis and his wife Liz I want to
say
let's let Lewis explain Lewis how's it
going hello how's it going thanks for
having me I appreciate you
well uh okay I'll explain so basically
my wife and I uh were on the channel
she's the host uh and it all uh happened
because she fell in love with the coffee
world she was working as a barista when
we moved to Canada and
of course
wait a minute wait a minute this is
accessing Archives this is insane we're
on coffee with candle yeah
we are now looking it's not that big of
a deal I suppose but I was even looking
at the Avatar your wife Liz she's
sipping on coffee I'm sipping on coffee
she's I guess the extent of my my
excitement but uh you gotta just press
record all right back to you uh Lewis go
ahead bring it down
all right so yeah basically you know
that Bina Barista is not like a high
paying job so we needed to move on but
she was so in love with coffee content
the coffee the coffee world that we were
like okay what can we do what can we do
on the weekend should we open a coffee
car and go to the park and I was like
okay we cannot afford a coffee business
but why don't we make a YouTube channel
so you can keep making coffee teaching
people and helping people enjoy better
coffee at home which is what we try to
live for
um and uh we jump into this world of
content creation back in September uh we
broke the Thousand uh subscriber count
uh like a month ago and here we are man
congrats that's amazing love the channel
the production's nice and crispy that's
really cool to see
um and uh I would love to what's your
question today all right well um it's uh
it's been always a struggle defining
what is the right content we need to
make and defining the Right audience
like it it never stops for us to wonder
if we're doing the right thing and uh
the thing is that when we look at other
successful coffee creators uh they
always focus a lot on reviewing uh gear
and reviewing gadgets and we try that
and if you see the most well viewed
video on the long form is a review a a a
scale coffee scale
um but it is pretty expensive to do we
are not Gearheads
um coffee tools that are actually worth
reviewing are pretty expensive coffee
machine and stuff like that so
uh we were like okay what else can we do
so uh I want you to look at the channel
you're a coffee lover I love that you
started with the uh this uh coffee
brands like what are you drinking today
we're allowed into a specialty coffee uh
of course
um so looking at the channel what do you
think the is the best type of content
that could appeal a wider audience but
still be like coffee Focus like we don't
want to have like a recipe Channel but
like really coffee focused yeah I gotcha
so you know one of the things we teach
in uh VRA is we talk about our 16
different
video formats
for
um
boosting the growth of any channel it's
in the master section of the video
reggae Academy we've been adding and
uploading these new videos and one that
many people are familiar with is asq
answer specific questions
um you're very familiar with that and so
we'll kind of go through a couple of
those because that's why we've created
systems
and Frameworks like that at um
our company and so I want to encourage
everyone watching too if you haven't
registered for the challenge you want to
go deeper the first sessions I call
about asq but when I think about answer
specific questions I I would always
start there and I would think about you
know coffee
um and maybe
throw a question mark on there or
something like uh coffee like what
coffee does to the body what machine to
buy what it does to your brain what
coffee do you use for espresso and
what's Wild is of course over time
there's maybe a lot of
um
competition here there can always be
updated answers to this you can look at
some of these shorts
so it doesn't we don't have to even go
very far we can start with just asq we
could head over here to vid IQ our
sponsor of today's coffee with candle
and use the keyword Search tool and type
in something like what coffee to make
for espresso look at the keywords how to
make espresso espresso for beginners
take something like espresso for
beginners uh espresso no X
proper pronunciation right uh espresso
um look at some videos like this and and
consider you know just because someone's
made it like you want to make these are
all ranked they're a little bit older
this is pretty good I mean that's best
machine you know that but a lot of
machine ones but a beginner's guide part
one what could you add to this
conversation so I if you noticed I was
just kind of zigging and zagging
following
coffee questions answering specific
questions about coffee read your
comments answer specific questions now
you mentioned review specific products
RSP would be another one of the content
formats what's cool about that is I
would I would have a vision and I'm sure
you do that there will be a day where
you will probably get unlimited coffee
equipment for free
um that is what's waiting on the other
side of having influence because brands
that are smart you know at least will if
anything lets you borrow or you know
some Brands lend us cameras other
cameras other companies give us cameras
um and different things that happen that
we get paid to also make videos brand
deals that's waiting for you down the
road but also thinking about maybe how
you could slice up like coffee
accessories and it may be you know what
are what are the lowest hanging fruit or
lower top three must-have espresso tools
though top ranking videos 2022 so like
you know a little just halfway into our
conversation and no one's got 2023 yet I
mean maybe they do but it's still ranked
on 2022 and people want recency so we're
two layers deep ours asq RSP
TSS teach specific skills
um the thing that I think would be
a little bit more out of the box would
potentially to be to do some challenges
and what I mean by challenges not the
five-day challenge we're doing
um but Mr Beast is really popularized
the challenge format like he sets the
stakes and he raises the stakes and this
would be dipping your toes a little bit
into entertainment
um if we play with this idea it might be
different than your style but like a
challenge that comes to mind
would be something like you know what
happens if you drink 21 shots of
espresso in one hour I'm not saying
that's on brand for you guys but that's
the way of thinking
um or is it possible to achieve
x with X could with an Aeropress could
you do this you know what are some
different things and it's setting up
things that could go viral on shorts
amongst the coffee Community they almost
have an entertainment Miss to them and
so uh espresso
espresso art
um and on shorts we got 144 568 like if
you're in this world
um oh my gosh there's a reason it's got
29 million views camel latte art did he
legit do that this is this is ridiculous
like we watch this together so
um you know that's all you might be like
is this a high level of skill could you
guys pull this out it is uh Liz she can
do later art uh that kind of stuff it's
a higher level
uh but yeah it's it's totally possible
so
um obviously on the other side of truly
building up your skills this is so rad
so is um is the fact that this short got
29 million views and what we're talking
about here is content format so that
would be this is kind of a challenge or
this is a wow effect and this isn't even
necessarily I'm sure non-coffee lovers
want to see this because it's absolutely
ridiculous
um and so you know having fun there
there would be another one
um and tapping into
other formats that are working well
across YouTube and then you're in VRA
yeah yeah I am so have you gone through
VRA Masters not completely so I know
that uh because also it's like a whole
new section we just added and we've been
adding new legit there's 16 different
um you know
uh videos in there another one would be
like react and and then there's
trainings to go deep of like where to
find the different stuff or whatever but
ultimately like a reaction video would
be thinking about
um you know viral coffee Clips or
something like that and then
I mean it's interesting viral coffee
tick tocks so viral coffee Tick Tock
like you could react to
this guy was testing them this is a
challenge so it looks like this guy
smart
um I don't know if maybe found
some
tick tocks that of coffee and then tried
them himself uh perhaps
um if there's a trend like this and so
the deeper we go what we can find and
that's the whole point of also our
community is to realize like sometimes
we can get into a rut sometimes we can't
see like you know outside of the box of
of what we could potentially do next but
there really is like unlimited levels of
depth I would argue so I tested viral
Tick Tock coffee recipes to see if they
work part nine by the way and so tapping
into and you maybe react to those you
tested those that's kind of combining
virality it's combining challenges and
then you can growth hack all of the
above because when you mix and match the
video strategies you can
use a short to get more awareness more
awareness leads to a brand that wants to
work with you a brand that wants to work
with you leads to sending you a bunch of
gear getting a bunch of Gears like oh
crap now we have tons of videos to make
about all this gear and then like more
of those doors open for a collaboration
and then uh somebody in Canada a Big
Brand wants to collaborate with you Dan
like not just trying to like put Pie in
the Sky out like that's what we
experience at think media not some kind
of a weird flex but there's like
boxes of gear in my garage that Kyle has
not picked up yet and I'm like Kyle bro
like there's all these microphones and
and I mean it's like a good problem to
have and I mean I'm sure someone's in
the comments like bro I could use a
microphone like send me a camera and I
get it but like we also have the
responsibility to so but we are in a
very blessed Place why this is it kind
of ties into the beginning of of this
whole coffee with candle
you gotta hustle and be resourceful at
the start the same way I was no Kyle no
Omar no Nolan just me just my wife just
making videos a thousand subscribers
like you guys
hustling one video at a time and using
the video formats that were Within Reach
to growth hack my way up and eventually
you actually have what's called
opportunity overwhelm you have so much
opportunity coming your way so many good
video ideas coming your way so many
different things like our Stormtrooper
friend Paul
so many maybe collabs everybody wants to
collab with them now in the Star Wars
cosplay Fitness but like it hasn't
happened yet and so on the other side of
taking massive action and uh really
being resourceful with where you're at
now has this given you any ideas yeah a
lot of ideas actually it's been really
great great advice we have been thinking
about uh uh the the tick tock challenges
uh tiktok recipes uh and actually we
managed to grow because of
um uh 101 way serious so we're making
almost daily videos we had to stop
because we're moving but uh we're on
coffee recipe number 43
um and that helped us grow a lot and
some of them we realized that are like a
little bit more viral than others
um on YouTube it's not uh the best it's
not the it's not being the best on
YouTube but Tick Tock kinda like helps
us drive some traffic as well so uh
we're experimenting on that end and I
wanted to like have a better
understanding on on how we can
capitalize on on that kind of content
yeah well you guys are doing great it's
super inspiring and really grateful that
you're part of our community congrats on
all these success and uh I want to
encourage you to just double down you
have a lot of momentum right now
um go for green as we say in VRA all the
time it's cool to see views are up Subs
are up you know videos published is up
four percent y'all you're putting in the
work I I have a sixth sense I hope you
know as as I should related to YouTube
and when I look at kind of where you've
been where you are and where you're
going your future is so bright I gotta
wear sunglasses oh and so there's a lot
of success waiting for you on the other
side of a lot of hard work and so double
down you guys are amazing and I really
appreciate you being a part of our
community and coming on coffee with
channel oh thank you your coffee hey
cheers
tell tell Liz hi and uh let's get coffee
sometime
all right peace
hey if you're getting value smash like
um if you're grateful smash the like
button and uh you know also iron
sharpens iron so if you're here in the
comments you know we have two more
guests today but if you have any
feedback any insights any video ideas
share those you know our guests are
hanging out and
um we're you know we care about this
community and we really know that your
ideas and your insights and
um I'm a big believer that um the best I
could think media it's not like the best
ideas come from just even Omar Nolan or
Sean like new people that jump on the
team like Brooke who just joined
um has a perspective and hasn't even
really been doing YouTube but might say
something like why don't you go why
haven't you guys done this and we're
like
it's an incredible idea because
sometimes you could get so close to the
problem of your own YouTube channel that
you need an outside perspective and so
um shout me out where you're watching
from if you're just jumping on we have
two more guests today on coffee with
Cannell and uh we also have a little bit
of q a coming in
Rylan says when you've got a video
that's hit the number one spot do you
let it ride for a while before
publishing again or keep it rolling
so I think what Rylan is saying is
whenever you post a new video
it gets ranked my current short posted
on think media today is 6 out of ten
so it's not number one but if it was a
number one the question is
do you let do you stop posting or do you
let it ride
it's kind of up to you there's different
schools of thought one is
you should
upload a video and wait 48 hours this is
a couple year old data point but it was
a data point so that the video can be
recommended properly hit the home page
properly and your videos don't compete
with themselves and my guilin from
Little Monster did some studying saying
like three days a week with about two
days uploading three times a week with
about two days in between each upload
was kind of an optimized amount of
uploading
here's the problem
he then was like unless you don't do
that and then you're that works too and
you're like what okay so it doesn't
matter and it was like like for example
look at the WWE Channel
he was and this has been true for years
he's like you know if you go to WWE are
you all subscribed to the WWE channel
are y'all WWE fans
he was like let's look at their Channel
stats
how many uploads did they do in the last
month 581.
so how many uploads is that a day I mean
one hour ago four hours ago seven hours
ago and and how many views sixty eight
thousand two hundred eighteen thousand
so what's his point well people make all
kinds of weird statements they'll be
like the secret number to the YouTube
algorithm
is two shorts at 2 36 A.M
4 33 a.m along the next day at six
Eastern Time
and then
a live stream for two hours following
and you're like what are you to and
they're like that is how you unlock The
DaVinci Code you know like dude The
DaVinci Code is heresy bro it's not even
real doc so listen
um
it doesn't matter number one I think
like you you don't letting it ride and
here's the bottom line I do think there
is something about
maybe taking a break there's also shorts
have entered the picture and so do
shorts even compete with your main
videos not really you know notifications
like how many people are going to get
notifications look at the stats not only
do only a few percentage of people get
notifications it then says this is how
many people actually have notifications
on so it's like they're not checking
their email notifications are silenced
on their phone
so what's the point the point is I think
just go for your next upload we like to
say about one a day unless we don't make
their respect we'll do one upload we'll
do a short and then I'm like I'm doing a
coffee with candle and then it's like
three in that day and and is that
perfect it may or may not be but the
future is forward man post videos
um and uh and then test and experiment
and see how things go the last thing I
need you to say as we get ready for the
next guest the last thing I need you to
know that is also direct from YouTube is
the cool thing about YouTube is each
video is judged on its own merits that
is something you can take to the bank
and what that would mean is like
while perhaps during its launch if like
YouTube could only recom you know if
it's not going to recommend multiple of
your videos on the home page at once so
you want to space out your uploads the
punch line is once a video starts to
take off
once the video gets a little love going
on it you know once it's got a little
momentum a little bit of watch time a
little bit of click-through rate every
video is judged on its own merits we
also know this because YouTube employees
have told us if you have a bad upload it
doesn't hurt your Channel
now it might hurt your brand because
people are like they have an experience
with that video but a lot of times the
video just gets killed algorithmically
so that's another reason why it's like
the volume game
upload 551 videos a month like the WWE
but there's a certain clip that's just
going to do well on its own and once it
starts doing well it's its own
click-through rate it's its own watch
time it's its own recommendations on the
suggested and home page that's letting
that video have a life of its own so
after you've had a number one it's also
not getting discouraged by the fact that
the one after it was the six because
maybe 100 days later that video ranks
but it's just about like the Futures
forward and post videos of course
strategically and analyze them but uh
don't worry about it too much I hope
that advice was helpful as we get ready
for our next guest accessing archives
like Sean like what are these sound
effects for like what do they even mean
I don't know I'm I'm working it out if
we're trying to figure out the coffee
with candle show I'm going to pull up
our next guests
Channel and uh it looks like we've got
Stacy on deck and Stacy has got a
channel called
Adventures of a lifetime
I'm going to welcome Stacy to the coffee
with candle show Stacy how are you hi
there thanks for having me I'm good um
it's adventure's gone wrong so just
correct you on that but um
okay let me make sure I'm on the right
channel it says Adventures of a lifetime
though
is that right am I on the right chin
no it's called adventure's gone wrong
okay then uh then let me look up a
different Channel
adventure's gone wrong yes right there
yeah that's perfect awesome okay wait
tell us about how long you've been on
here what you're up to okay so um this
is my second channel so you talking
earlier about you know your earlier
channels or kind of stepping stones and
that's what this kind of has been for me
so I've been on YouTube about three
years with a kind of like a vloggy type
Channel and then I kind of I've always
wanted to do like documentary style
filmmaking and tell stories and that's
what this is about so it's kind of me
just telling stories and um about all
different Adventures gone wrong
that makes total sense so they're kind
of video essays you can look up this
information pull together photos pull
together be wrong
and tell these stories I do all the
research yeah for them and it's been so
fun that I really love it I've kind of
dropped off the other channel because
I'm like I'm not even interested in that
anymore because I'm having so much fun
with this one and it's doing pretty well
so I'm just and I don't have that many
videos out so far because they take
quite a long time to make yes um so yeah
so I was just wondering my question was
actually how to get going like full time
onto YouTube like
um
like the monetization monetization type
of things um you know the obvious things
like that you've talked about before but
I'm just wondering what would be because
this is like a storytelling Channel I'm
not really doing the educational type
thing so I can't really go the route of
like creating courses you know but I
could probably do a patreon or something
um or is it even just too soon to even
think about that should I just I mean
I'm gonna keep making videos and I've
only got really like 10 out there
um so yeah like I just kind of don't
know what my next step are other than
making videos yeah how close are you to
monetization
oh I've got it okay I'm monetized on for
AdSense yeah and these might these are
my early videos and they're just you
know you talk about your early videos
being bad and I look back and it's kind
of like oh man there's so much I could
have fixed but also yeah but also not
bad at all in the sense of the fact that
uh I mean 86 000 views and and uh so
cool to see how what you're doing here
well first of all
um this is inspiring it's awesome to see
what you're doing second of all I want
to hear a little bit more from you that
I know will be encouraging to our
community with the fact that you pivoted
your Niche and started a new channel
what were you doing before
it was like a vlog type Channel I live
in like a cabin in the woods and I kind
of had like a the off-grid life cabin
life
um kind of Vlogs and um I really like
doing it and it was kind of my way just
to get into filmmaking I really wanted
to make documentaries and I did make a
short one before I started my first
channel and then someone had said oh
make it make a documentary or do a
YouTube channel about your friends and
then they moved away and I'm like I'll
just do one about myself I don't really
want to be on camera but I'll just do
one and you know I have a good little
crew a group of people you know I've got
like 5 000 subscribers on that channel
and it's like a super great little
community that I'm a part of with all
the other off-grid people and um so I'm
Gonna Keep it going but then I was just
like I want to tell stories and I've
always been into like adventures and
stuff like that and I didn't really see
too much of that you know I'm a big fan
of all the storytelling channels on
YouTube so I wanted to do something kind
of like that but in my own kind of vibe
like with the adventures
so then I you know and then I started
researching these stories and they just
fired me up because they're also
interesting and I try and find ones that
people aren't you know don't know about
so I have to do a lot of research into
them and um people seem to like it so
yeah it was a total pivot and just based
on my what my passion was and like I can
tell like I'm way more passionate about
it so I'm like you know working evenings
and weekends on it I kind of lose track
of time when I'm editing because it
takes so long
um but yeah that whole you know do what
you're passionate about really
resonated with me
yeah and I love this case study because
you know
um this is one of the things we teach in
our Niche Finder course not only did you
get a lot of insights from that first
thing you did but that you're the first
version of your YouTube channel might
not be the thing that is exciting it's
also or is the thing that ultimately
works and
um even if it could pivoting is okay
starting something new is okay and I
think what you're on you're doing right
here is gold it's also seems to have
grown faster than your original Channel
as well
um the first thing before diving into
the channel is of course you also have
this other group and this other channel
but one of the big opportunities I think
you have is
focusing your energy and completely
letting go of the other channel
yeah I mean
I think four months went by but
and then I
like you know it wasn't uh even my mom
was like that wasn't your best
it wasn't mom but and are you and then
are you you said you're working like
nights and stuff so then what's the main
thing that you're juggling
oh just like a full-time job so this you
know like full-time nine to five Monday
to Friday kind of job and this is so
intensive editing right like it takes me
this last video which is all ready to go
tomorrow it took me like three and a
half weeks to edit because of you know
the full-time work and stuff and and
they're also longer videos like uh my
one it surprised me that a 33 minute
video did so well so I'm like well I
might as well do some longer ones too I
like doing shorter ones but then I
thought I'll just do another longer one
so yeah so they're very long and that's
what the issue have you defined your
exit amount like the amount of money you
need to earn that would allow you to
create your job I've got an idea
yeah I think that um I mean one thing
that I would love for you to do is get a
note card
um three if possible
um and maybe behind your computer
monitor on your bathroom door or mirror
should you choose to do it
um give yourself like as as a sign or as
a as a Target
um that dot that amount and the reason I
say that is just because when we when it
comes to focusing our energy and you
sound like you're very focused but even
back to
number one again you got this other
channel you got friends you want to Vlog
you want to do that as well great but
anything that you're doing
at we only have limited time and you
especially all of us there's something
about getting even tripling down on
Focus because I actually believe full
time is a lot closer than you realize
and by becoming obsessed I also
have you ever heard me talk about the 25
rule
um I'm not sure I don't think so so if
we and it could be more or less probably
more but let's say the number's four
thousand dollars so you put four
thousand dollars on a note card the 25
Rule and everyone could follow along
that's listening can do this as well
question number one how much money do
you need to be able to quit your job and
work from home and do this full-time
Define that number caveat not to find
that number eating Uber Eats 14 times a
day and like paying for a car payment
that's ridiculous or what but like if
you were to really want to create
Freedom maybe even reducing the cost of
Lifestyle or whatever what is that exit
number let's pretend it's four thousand
dollars
tip two the 25 rule states that is soon
as you're earning 25 of that number
you could potentially give your two
weeks notice
three that would be assuming you have
some savings and one of the things you
could be doing right now is diverting
even more money to savings because that
exit Point could be in 30 days 60 days
90 days four imagine no full-time job in
you working on this channel
what happens
does that three-week video be able to be
done in one week
sooner
yeah much sooner
maybe maybe
two days
what a dream and I would actually so
if how close are you to 25 of the
channel earning what you would need to
live on a month
um well that one video just keeps doing
well so I'm just relying on AdSense is
that that's all I'm making right now
right so I mean it's doing better than I
more than I ever made on my last channel
in three years right so it's it's uh how
close are you already there
uh no I
probably like 10 okay so yeah so so what
I mean should you choose to do the
activity in anybody put the put the exit
number so that you visually see it it's
a reminder to also say there's this
other like stuff I want to dabble in but
I'm going to stop dabbling in anything
that doesn't lead to directly uh
monetizing as we talk about monetize
I do think ad revenue for channels like
this is a big play for you because
there's million viewed and multi-million
viewed videos in your future and also
because they're longer video essays and
stories there's the map multiple ad
spots that can be very lucrative people
will watch them to the end because once
they're hooked so it's a really good
model and so all that to say is I think
the power Focus to finding some of those
numbers of course
you gotta know your own risk threshold
and risk tolerance and don't email me if
you're you're homeless after uh but but
I mean but legit the 25 rule because
it's a huge leap of faith but what it
proves is assuming you got some cushion
and let's say you even had like one two
three months four or five whatever you
want kind of like a Dave Ramsey
emergency fund
man there's something powerful that
happens when you can sleep and you don't
have to go to your job anymore but you
don't what I would you don't do that
when you're at 10 like the 25 rule is
like this channel has proven to pay 25
30 because ad revenue is coming in on
some of the videos I've done
hey boss I'm I'm I need to get my two
weeks hey I would love it if you I mean
where's the prize we want you to work
here longer okay three or four like
whatever but like but then you start to
transition you take that leap and and
then you I think you'll be able to uh
ultimately jump and get there faster but
as we land the plane and I look at the
channel what do you think about that
um yeah I think that's a good way to go
about it and I I wasn't really sure
about the AdSense thing if that would be
enough
um so that's really good to hear that it
could bring in some good AdSense in the
future because I was looking at like
okay do I do merchandise do I go for
sponsors do I go for patreon you know
there's so many different options but I
think that again and I would be
different advice that I give to
different people that's why the context
of this conversation is so important the
this particular content format is
monetizing views based on
um on you know people watching the
content and I do think those other
streams could be in your future but in
one sense do you happen to know what
your RPM is your Revenue per thousand
views yeah I think it's like eight
dollars
see and that's phenomenal a so then you
know if if you need
uh a million views at an eight dollar
RPM is eight grand
so so then you start going back if that
can hold true across all of your videos
um if eight grand was the uh a
meaningful number per month then you're
just like well how do I get a million
views and you've got one that's got half
a million already and some that are
continuing to get views or whatever so
then you you could just again double
down on that and then eventually it's a
flywheel effect because once people fall
in love with some of your videos they're
like man and they start watching others
because you're creating these
masterpieces so it's another one of
those examples where uh I think you're a
lot closer than you realize there's a
lot of hustle waiting for you on the
other side but I would go all in on
AdSense and then I think finally
you know the other things that could
exist in your future could be like
you know uh
this is kind of complex if you get into
like your own physical product or
something but
um
uh if you go to like multi-tools
on Ali AliExpress or something you could
potentially have like a branded you
could put your you you could put
something on your Channel
that has your logo on it or something
custom that you make
um and you could set up you know Drop
Shipping of some kind or something
um yeah where you bring in
um you know something cool like this
outdoor tool and you order a couple
different prototypes and you find one
that you actually like and you know
could be something cool like this and as
you build up fans you you create
something that people the the other cool
thing about something like this is like
I'm
I'm a domestic Outdoors man you know
like I I like going outside love running
I even have a Thule backpack that I put
my son in and I go on this like it seems
like the Wilderness I am in a suburban
area with like one Trail then if I'm on
my stories people like is he hiking in
the mountains
it's like no and that's that's what
resonates with people is because I cover
stories where just uh everyday dad Who
Loved bike riding went out one Sunday
and got impaled by a branch and you know
and then he was in the hospital and and
he actually saw my video and he loved it
which was like the ultimate test of
perfect I don't I'm the everyday dad I
don't want to get into the branch people
getting lost in the woods like all they
needed was like a safety device or a
whistle or something right so there's a
lot a ton of options on stuff like that
and so that right there by the way not
that hear me of course we're all ethical
marketers here but like one of the
things that it is good to Market to is
people's fears like if you have an
audience and you're like if this
episode's brought to you by a whistle so
you don't get impaled real Branch you're
like everyone buys it at the end of the
story because they're like dude
um and and so you know but but I was
gonna say that as like a domestic
Outdoorsman I love stuff like this
though like oh give me a cool like yeah
give me something and they um I wonder
there's probably plenty of places that
would um
uh and you could just type in your logo
and they would like engrave it on the
leather or something and and whatever
the punchline is this is a good
conversation because too many people
back to the theme of today's coffee with
candle they start working on this stuff
too soon I think I think that like this
is in your future but what you need to
do is shut out all distractions make the
greatest videos possible and reach that
freedom moment of
quit putting your two weeks from ad
Revenue because that's going to work for
you
then as you now are at home and you
maybe start leveraging things and
learning how to Outsource a few things
or get even a little bit of extra money
buy yourself some margin get some more
sleep
there's really cool things in your
future where I do believe you could have
some super fans and maybe Channel
memberships or patreon I do believe with
survival whistles and different like
that that outdoor industry is really
cool survival stuff uh the multi-tools
that have the fishing line and all that
kind of stuff and I think that ties in
your channel so all of that's very
exciting and you can kind of business
plan that out but our next action is
like blinders on
make your best videos and reach freedom
and consider the the 25 rule because I
really of course it takes faith and it's
scary and it's going to take risk but I
think it's a practical rule you've
proven that working on your side hustle
without sleep
at night after work early mornings
you're able to get to 25 of your needed
monthly Revenue
you pull the a jack cord and then go all
in
and uh I think you're gonna get there a
lot faster than you think
awesome well then I'm not going to look
into all these other merch Ops or
different options that I was looking at
earlier and waste time on those so
that's good to know well it's a distress
it's a distraction right now because yes
yeah you have a concept here you're
great at thumbnails these videos are
great you've you've do this again
obviously done but just just do it again
a couple of times and good RPM and
you're going to uh you've got incredible
things in your future really grateful to
get to talk to you today Stacy awesome
thanks so much this has been amazing
appreciate you okay thanks
all right friends we got Debbie on next
and uh I want to thank you for being
here what has been your aha moment so
far today on coffee with candle we've
had some great combos if you're just
joining I actually really want to
encourage you to save this episode
um and uh re-watch it we've talked
today's kind of like the biz Dev episode
we've talked with uh Paul doing
Stormtrooper Fitness stuff and we're
talking about the business that you
build around your YouTube channel
um we have Debbie on in just a second
but I do want to remind you you can
still get into
our free challenge in the on-demand
replays are there I'm going to be live
tomorrow morning for our last live
session but you can watch the first four
sessions actually check this out I want
to invite you guys to our YouTube 1K
challenge you can join this challenge
for free as we show you how to grow your
first 1000 subscribers and make your
first one thousand dollars on YouTube
we've had countless people join us
during this 1K challenge who are now at
a thousand subscribers and past a
thousand subscribers making money on
YouTube and you could be the next person
if you just go to tube1kchallenge.com
you can sign up for the very next
challenge and we can't wait to see you
guys there
yeah so tube1k challenge.com Link in the
description down below if you want to
register
um you'll have over the weekend to watch
the replay so even if you can't be there
for the live session uh definitely be a
part of that it is totally free
um there is like you there's a special
discount on our starter kit should you
want it there is a VIP option which at
this point probably isn't relevant
because we only have one more q a
however you can still be a part of that
if you happen to be joining while we're
live here and so those are options for
you but you don't have to join any of
that stuff you could be a part of our
Challenge and watch the on-demand
replays for free at tube 1K
challenge.com and so
um check that out and I'm excited to
have Debbie on the show for our final
guest today Debbie how's it going good
good thanks for having me on oh thanks
so much for jumping on and I'm gonna
pull your channel up Devi's healthy
kitchen and tell us a little bit about
what you're doing on YouTube
well
um I started my YouTube channel actually
back in April of 21 where I was
uploading Facebook lives uh healthy
cooking recipes and uh came across you
on YouTube one day
um decided I needed to make some changes
because the vertical videos were like 11
minutes long wasn't going anywhere so I
joined VRA this last November and it's
made a big difference
um you know I've been improving my
thumbnails I just hit
1133 Subs but my watch hours are like
25.87 and by looking at my channel you
would think it's a cooking channel
because it's Debbie's healthy kitchen
and I've been sharing healthy recipes
however I feel like I'm missing some
opportunity here because I am a
certified health coach and there's so
much more to what I can offer besides
healthy recipes so I believe it starts
in the kitchen you know getting healthy
but I would like to Pivot a little bit
by adding in you know health and
wellness to showing people what services
I can actually help them with and maybe
even sharing some of my own experiences
I lost 69 pounds by following a specific
program and I'm just not sure how to
you know make those changes I guess if I
if I really should stick with just the
nutrition piece
um you know I'm really not sure because
I feel like it's time to make a change
uh so thoughts on what I can do to Pivot
or if I should and how to keep my
engagement of my current audience but
also attract others you know with other
areas and health
great questions and great
um I want to acknowledge you for just
all the work you've put in it's not easy
uploading 167 videos you've crossed the
Thousand subscriber Mark you have an
incredible foundation and I think
um I can really feel how you may feel
now after 167 videos
after yes 139 000 views
and a thousand subscribers there's no
doubt though a level of fatigue or like
I have some growth but is it really
working is it you know worth doing am I
doing it right and do I need to Pivot
and in my opinion the answer is no
you don't need to Pivot you need to
double down on what you're doing but
improve what you're doing as we say
small tweaks lead to Giant Peaks here's
why I think that
recipes and your current promise your
current promise your current brand is so
strong like it just it is you've got an
incredible Vibe you've got the education
you've got the experience to make videos
you've got
the history you've got the expertise and
This Promise of like from quick lunches
to family dinners I've got you covered
the idea of healthy as well
um so there's a niche within the niche
of of what you're cooking massive demand
for healthy recipes around the world
um
and on the one sense you've been working
so hard for so long but I feel like
you've kind of now gotten to a
a foundation to build on like in a way a
day one because like this has been
preparation for you to absolutely start
to shine so with that when I think about
like tweaking there are certain things
if we get into more of like a channel
review here
um I think that like there's a lot of
words on the cover I think there could
be some branding and design improvements
like if you're looking to get healthy
and love to cook you're in the right
place I'm cooking I mean it's clear
you've already ever it's it's there's
actually really nothing wrong with the
cover but I feel like
like uh you don't necessarily
need to have I like less is more in
terms of the same way we would teach on
thumbnails in terms of kind of if you
will The Branding and the look of things
um and then I think that
doubling down let's we'll talk a little
bit about the content and the topics and
the thumbnails in just a second but I
think everything you're describing
is could be part of your journey I think
you should have a free meum of some kind
of uh shopping list for people and start
building an email list but I think that
that is a natural integration into the
videos you're already making it's not
that you have to go into like Health
coaching it's just and also if you're
interested in getting healthy or you're
interested in
um making different decisions at the
grocery store make sure to get my free
and to creating some like really
irresistible what we'd call a lead
magnet
um that could lead to other Biz Dev
things I think your ability to
you said coach people right describe
your expertise to me
yeah so I
I certify by taking a course
um and it's a specific program but I
talk to people find out what their needs
are and then um it's based on nutrition
and so I will just help them guide them
through the program really help motivate
be their best cheerleader that kind of
thing but also hold them accountable to
their health goals so with weekly
check-ins and is that are you already
doing that yeah I'm already doing that
you have clients yes that your full-time
thing
and you have enough clients no never
okay so you can take on more so if we
could get more from the YouTube channel
yes that's the goal got it so so yeah I
think the path you're on and that's
going to be adding in some skill sets
that do you have a current have you ever
set up like a landing page for
collecting people's emails and giving
away a free pdf
um
recipes or shopping list or anything
like that before
no I haven't done that I mean it's on my
list of things
Banner
um click here and you know get their
email and all of that but I haven't set
that up yet I wasn't sure I was holding
off to find out what direction I really
wanted to go here yeah what my dream
scenario
is tweaks to the videos videos that are
blowing up inside of the videos people
get to know you and then learn about
a free way to connect with like a free
way to get so you can contact them at a
deeper level a lead magnet Something
Free and then your follow-up sequence
with them just lets people know if
they're right for coaching so you
eventually have an endless stream of
leads an endless like pre-qualification
of clients that could work with you and
an endless stream of clients and people
essentially on a waiting list to work
with you while you're having fun making
more content and probably eventually
you're too busy there's no way you I
mean you're you're always full there's
always a waiting list and then content
is just a bonus monetization and all of
that other stuff
um can come as well and so
that being said it there's kind of two
battles to fight one battle is the
setting
of all of that up
um and once it's set up and once you
could do the call to actions and whatnot
it's powerful because you could just let
people know you know go to uh
healthykitchenchecklist.com and grab the
um my
you know or yeah healthykitchenlist.com
you can get my free shopping list and
and then there's email sequences and
stuff so it's kind of a conversation for
a separate time but then from that point
what I would want to do
is
is be thinking about VRA and have you by
chance watched VRA Masters
um not recently but I have gone through
it awesome because we are adding some
new stuff so I encourage you to check
that out and to our conversation earlier
um where we're talking to the coffee
Channel thinking about
some out of the box like for you I'm now
asking like okay
these practical recipe videos are great
but what has the potential where can we
mine for gold that's what a VRA is a lot
about like what are the topics and that
topics could be trending summer is
certainly trending but what's on
people's minds it could be maybe it
could be summer what are the topics
though I also think about maybe some
things that are related to trending
diets what happens if we tap into
something that's keto related you don't
got to be a keto Channel but what if you
tap into keto what if you tap into a
vegan recipe doesn't have to be a vegan
Channel I see that it's not but like
there's that option and I and I'm not
even fully sure like if I go uh I would
look up something like 2023 trending
diets so this would be kind of that
market research and so Mediterranean
perhaps the DASH diet a flexitarian diet
um you research that you find something
cool my point is this waiting for you on
the other side
of the right topic with the right title
at the right time is a hundred thousand
views is a quarter million views is a
video that over the next four years gets
a million views because your
flexitarian hamburger I don't know if
that's a thing so let's see so your
video should you you know care about it
your video of the flexitarian
meal prep
um let's just hypothetically say get 16
million views I don't know like nine and
flexible at whatever it is about us
flexitility meal prep they got that's
only 2 000 but uh you know whatever so
uh that that would be the process as we
go through Masters like whether it's
covering not that you have to be trendy
but related to your ethics meaning you
know your philosophy of what how you
would help people tying into what's
happening
in the world uh one of my
friends who's crushing it on YouTube
with a lot of faceless channels
he summarizes YouTube by saying this
all that YouTube is
is human psychology and trends
it's human psychology and trends
and
that's one aspect of course there's also
like practicality search based videos
and that's like your base and VRA but
that's why in VRA Masters we've added so
much more content because a 2023 2024
YouTube world is you're one video away
from a combination of one of your
favorite diets adapted to something that
Dr Oz just talked about
adapted to even pulling a clip in from
Dr Oz should you know putting him in the
thumbnail you actually reacting to a
clip trying that recipe and then people
being like man Debbie's so cool and I am
trying to like eat more healthy grabbing
your thing and I would imagine like
what's the maximum number of clients you
could take
oh gosh I would say one
yeah so
on the other side of a video hitting a
million views you might be maxed out
like and and on the other side of let's
make it more practical of your next 30
videos 10 doing not great the next 10
doing all right
three doing like thousands of views but
then like seven
three more doing 50 000 views but then
one of those gets 558 000 views like
your your client pipeline is full it's
overflowing
um and so anyways has that been helpful
some ideas and I want to encourage you
dive into the VRA Master section because
I believe it's it's really the 3.0
version of your channel you've had
incredible success up until this point
um and I love that we got to have this
conversation because many of us and
those watching on coffee with candle
live are on the replay
sometimes I'm glad you brought it up
because without an outside perspective
you might have there is sometimes where
maybe I would have been like for sure
you need to Pivot it's like it's not
working change it do something new
from my in my humble opinion it's about
doubling down but tweaking what you're
doing like doubling down on the recipes
on because that's a proven content
format tying it into how there's going
to be a path to work with you I want to
talk about you know that's going to be a
key and then applying these VRA Master
strategies
on some new recipes
you're a couple videos away when all
those things align and it doesn't have
to be perfect like I mean you might not
have the email list set up and the free
gift you see and then you might have a
video break out and you'll be like dang
it though that one Sean's exactly right
got 866 000 views and I had nowhere to
send anyone but I mean your channel grew
and you know we're all doing it messy
like so but those would be the the next
three moves you know thinking about the
email list thinking about the free gift
thinking about the follow-up sequence
that allows people to do a calendly or
however those 100 people total could
sign up with you meanwhile doing some of
these uh 3.0 VRA uh Master strategies on
your recipe videos layered on top of all
the skills that have led you to this
point I just absolutely am confident
that you have what it takes you've got
the talent the skills the ability I mean
looking at your channel you got the
energy the whole thing it's it's it's
amazing I think it's really and and I
was gonna say I think your thumbnails
are great I think that uh the only tweak
I might make to them in some cases is
one I do think you actually could be
zoomed in more I don't think you have to
have as much body in a lot of cases as
this it's still probably fine I also
think that too
a lot of great food videos do good with
just the food as on its own if you
success leaves clothes if you go like
air fryer Cod
I think what you're going to see hey you
rank for airfryer car that's cool maybe
it's not a huge but if we go let's see
air fryer Cod maybe that's because we
said in minutes
um you know the top ranked videos
you do have a couple with a person but
the top I mean everything on there is
the food is the hero itself so I think
that goes into experimenting I think
there's the personal brand piece of
having yourself in the thumbnail but
there's also the aspect because even
let's see this top person
uh jumps in
is not on camera so there's like a
faceless videos okay interesting let's
look at this one dash of spices
um also
interesting that I know we're going
along here and I'm diving back into it
we gotta land the plane but I would say
uh you know success leaves Clues and
this would be also researching looking
out okay what are some of the video
formats and whatnot that are out there
related to what I'm creating and what
could I learn from those
um but back to it by getting back into
VRA checking out some of those modules
you're doing you're doing great it's
tweaking what you're doing as you go
forward
has this been helpful very helpful I
appreciate it thanks so much I
appreciate you Debbie thanks so much for
coming on coffee with Channel
thanks
all right man give Debbie some love and
all of our guests some love today for
the last one hour and 38 minutes we have
been
going deep on YouTube
it's been one of my favorite episodes
and I'm excited about
um you being here so I want to thank you
for being here cheaper living in Andrew
Peterson
um I
I'm going to take another sip of coffee
and
um it looks like a few questions have
come in I'll answer two of those one of
those
dylan327 says to you guys
have a decently recent video on
optimizing ads in your video on very
newly monetized and started learning
that process we do we happen to have a
recent video
over on think media if you haven't heard
about our Channel think media that's
kind of that'd be a cool world I mean
I'm sure it's possible this channel is
called our think media podcast Channel
um
Nolan mole has a video called
I clicked this button and doubled my
YouTube income
and it is all about
multiple ad spots in your video and all
of that kind of stuff and so if you
happen to be watching this on the replay
that'll be in the description for you
and I recommend you go directly to that
subscribe to this channel
as well because there's a lot of great
stuff coming out for you over there and
our final question from Rylan says if uh
I'd like to get a course created how
important is it to have video set up to
publish during a break of 30 days
that's up to you it's back on like you
know
you could just batch some videos so you
keep them going
YouTube themselves the team over there
would say you can take a break and
you're not going to get penalized people
who analyze the data say um sometimes
people
depends on how long the break is and so
uh sometimes it actually builds demand
and people will
be pumped when you come back
I think that I'll just answer how what I
would do I I am a big consistency guy
and so I would probably try to batch
some videos maybe some simple ones like
one question one answer from the
community or answer specific questions
shoot for eight of those schedule upload
one a week it would take me like two
weeks if I'm a solo Creator to get ready
for my next six weeks but if I was
looking a couple months ahead I would
spend like two weeks batching doing the
thumbnails doing the editing getting the
videos ready getting them optimized
schedule uploading
for the next three four weeks
one a week comes out then I would put my
head down and hustle on building a
course or building out the next thing or
whatever
that's how I would do it I think many
examples valuetainment Patrick but David
with a huge Channel just like shut
everything down to work on the channel I
think for like a month to kind of
reinvent themselves or whatever others
have also taken a month break and they
just kind of stop and maybe do a
community tab post or you let people
know or something so it kind of is up to
you
you know I don't want to sit here and
say like don't be afraid that your
Channel's gonna die because I would I I
would I mean not maybe like afraid
because I will not fear for the Lord is
with me but I I'm probably a little
anxious a little bit paranoid of and so
it's it may be somewhere in between it
is sort of a personal choice
um but uh yeah I hope that helps coffee
with candle that is our show and uh I
want to thank you spirit away for being
here and adventure's gone wrong
appreciate you thanks for coming on
um I will say if you have not got into
the challenge the cool thing about going
there right now the next thing to do is
you can go watch four sessions for free
on demand they're not going to be
available forever they're actually only
available to those that are a part of
our current offer at vrafam.com we
actually are doing a special on video
ranking Academy if you have not heard
you know only a couple times a year we
do a challenge like this where there's a
lot of extra cool bonuses and some
really cool stuff that's happening
that's at vrafam.com but whether that's
right for you or not no big deal
the people who join vrafam.com get the
recordings for the challenge because
these are high value there's five quick
tips
and there's five deep dive sessions and
that's all included in people that are
joining VRA they get lifetime access to
those recordings during this special
offer at vrafam.com the point is you
could get access to that content I was
just describing for free from The
Challenge the replays of our challenge
sessions all week week long are in the
circle area right now entirely free and
so just check this video out this is how
you get access to that I want to invite
you guys to our YouTube 1K challenge you
can join this challenge for free as we
show you how to grow your first 1000
subscribers and make your first one
thousand dollars on YouTube we've had
countless people join us during this 1K
challenge who are now at a thousand
subscribers and past a thousand
subscribers making money on YouTube and
you could be the next person if you just
go to 21kchallenge.com you can sign up
for the very next challenge and we can't
wait to see you guys there
so if you go to two 1kchallenge.com then
you can register
um for free for that
um Joseph asked if I just wanted to get
the AI guide which is a brand new bonus
we've created it's a living document
we've invested thousands of hours
already into researching AI across our
team members myself and Nolan and Drea
and Kyle so ultimately
um that we're still working on like
launching the proper page for that
um you can connect with us at
thinkmediasupport.com if you're
interested in just like one-off or if
you're already in VRA and there was
something that's in this current bundle
that you're interested in
um hit us up at
www.thinkmediasupports.com and we can
help you with isolating one of those
things out but Joseph's right there is
some incredible things not just video
record Academy but our camera confidence
course
um our Niche Finder course
um our AI guide of course you get access
to the private Facebook group there's
even our social media accelerator for
those that are joining
um within like the next 36 hours it's
just a cool extra bonus where we had
chalene Johnson and Brock Johnson and
benazotti break down Instagram
some of our guests today had uh
uh we're talking about you know their
tick tocks their Instagrams their
Facebooks and multiplying content across
platforms we do like to caution new
YouTube creators from doing too many
things too soon kind of the theme of
today but what's cool is because there's
lifetime access for this offer at
vrafam.com you actually get access to
not just like the 101 content but this
thing will will carry you all the way
through your journey of
part-time full-time six-figure build a
million dollar Media company like the
levels of ranking videos getting more
sophisticated like we have benazadi from
keto Camp do an entire hour-long session
where he talks about how he started to
scale a team how he started to hit um
hire people how we started to post
content on multiple platforms monetize
in multiple ways honestly it's like a
much more advanced thing wouldn't even
be the thing I recommend you watch first
but that's included like that's all at
vrafam.com
um if you join by Friday at midnight on
the west coast is when you also get that
social media accelerator so anyways just
in case anyone's on the fence or has any
questions about any of that stuff
um definitely check that out my friends
this has been coffee with candle I'm
Sean Cannell rhymes with YouTube channel
and I appreciate you so much subscribe
if you're not subscribed hit like if you
got value today and I will see you on
the next episode peace out